hai sbagliato Questa è la tua punizione
adatta
è stato lui non è vero È stato lui
No no no
alzati
Batman
[Applauso]
in prigione
siamo tornati nuovissima Challenge a
scuola Chi vincerà le tre Challenge sarà
promosso chi invece perderà anche solo
una delle Challenge verrà bocciato per
ogni Challenge ci saranno le stelline
d'oro Chi vincerà la Challenge
collezione no le varie stelline d'oro e
alla fine chi avrà più stelline d'oro
verrà promossa e vincerà la Challenge e
dovremo affrontare la maestra cattiva ma
ora siete pronti partecipanti di questa
Challenge sono io professor
[Musica]
Vitale
[Applauso]
Dimmi il bullo che hai da guardare
Ehi Ma chi sarà la maestra
io non ho visto nessuno ancora e forse
devo ancora arrivare magari arriverà
momenti Eh sento dei passi sta arrivando
sta arrivando
[Musica]
o forse ha sbagliato classe
tu la maestra
Io sono la maestra
tritata Rossa
[Musica]
una maestra trita ossa Ma se sei una
bambina
scusa cosa hai detto
ho detto che sei una bambina non puoi
essere una maestra
ma con ah ah ah ah ah ah hai capito
perché il maestro trita ossa Mi sa che è
meglio comportarci bene con questo
maestra nella mia classe dovete stare
seduti è composti se no le vostre ossa
Ok ok maestra saremo sicuramente seduti
bene composti Ma qual è la prima lezione
come prima lezione sarà la Challenge di
inglese chi sbaglia avrà una penitenza
si tratta lo scoprirete fra poco siete
pronti Avete studiato inglese
Io adoro l'inglese La mia materia
preferita non vedo l'ora di iniziare la
verifica cioè la Challenge inglese
[Musica]
io conosco
Federico
iniziamo la Challenge
[Musica]
a ogni turno dovrete disegnare la parola
che c'è scritta qua chi sbaglia avrà una
penitenza se vi vedo copiare o
imbrogliare per te chiusi qua in
prigione Ehi se ti fate per me lasciate
un mi piace qua sotto Vitale vieni qua
la lavagna
io per primo
dunque quindi se ho capito bene devo
disegnare qui il significato di questa
parola qui in inglese
[Musica]
adesso mi ricordo
Hummer America hai sbagliato
ahmer significa martello Questa è la tua
punizione adatta
la penitenza di Vitale era proprio il
martello
seconda parola Anita vieni alla lavagna
Eccomi eccomi Allora io lo so Adesso lo
so la parola è teacher e Ah è vero Devo
disegnarla
non offenderti se la disegno male
Mamma mia l'ho disegnata proprio brutta
Comunque teacher vuol dire insegnante
giusto Sì brava Finalmente qualcuno che
ha studiato Ma posso parlare un po' in
inglese adesso perché io adoro parlare
in inglese loro in inglese posso parlare
un pochino in inglese no vai a posto
[Musica]
ora è il turno di chiappe eccomi qua
ora la parola che ho scelto per te è
Worms tieni
che cosa sia però il disegno lo faccio
[Musica]
Ma cosa è è un disegno con il mio
disegno maestra ma non significa questo
e non so cosa dire per me questo Works e
questo ora la tua penitenza sarà mettere
la mano nei Fermi
Metti subito subito
Fermi e quindi la penitenza da mettere
la mano nei vermi questa maestra è un
po' cattiva adesso vai
[Applauso]
a posto
tocca a te Billy Vieni alla lavagna
Eccomi eccomi maestra
disegna Jenny tieni
[Musica]
Sì io lo so cosa vuol dire io lo so
sì
un secondo un secondo che mi fa male la
pancia un secondo posso Posso girarmi Mi
fa male la pancia
[Musica]
finito finito
ho finito
sul telefono non ce l'ho il telefono non
ce l'ho No no Che cos'è questo questo
telefono ora sarà sequestrato
[Applauso]
[Musica]
sì subito Sì imbrogliatoi giusto deve
andare in prigione brava maestra la
maestra Ma perché mi è qui sempre
giovane perché imbrogliato
Così non faccio lezione
come hai detto
No dai dai dai dai è successo già qui
sono già pronti Allora
vuoi parlare ancora
perché questa ci doveva capitare
[Musica]
secondo round Vitale Vieni alla lavagna
Io lo so io lo so che cos'è E tu
cacche che schifo
ma no non è cacche è cake e poi parli tu
che ti chiami
e qui mi sento molto molto sicuro di
indovinata Questa quando si tratta di
cibo D'altronde Allora quindi cake
abbiamo
torta con la candelina Ho messo anche la
candelina perché sono bravissimo Bravo
bravo Vitale però quando si tratta di
cibo tu lo sai sempre quindi adesso
dov'è la mia torta
ma credo avevi solo disegnare
prima che ho sbagliato Ho preso il
martello in testa adesso che ho
indovinato Mi aspetto la torta no se non
fai a posto subito te ne do altre
cose
Ahia ma anche quando lo indovino prendo
le martellate Anita vieni a Lavagna
Eccomi eccomi qua Però vabbè lo so
benissimo che cos'è Ora lo disegno
subito
scusa che non so disegnare molto bene
Comunque ho disegnato uno zaino si
capisce Sì brava brava Hai indovinato
Sì però ok ora vai a posto
a un altro Disegna la parola
la parola Socrate disegno bene
questo Questo è il mio disegno per me ha
un significato Ma poi cosa è questa
schifezza che so che significa
calze
Questa è la tua Baby Creta
un calzino puzzolente
cosa stai zitto
[Musica]
Ok ora vai a posto
anzi questo te lo tieni pure tu Che
schifo
[Applauso]
prima Challenge completata la vincitrice
è Anita
Evviva ho vinto la prima Challenge ho
preso la mia prima stellina speriamo di
vincere anche le altre
Uffa Spero di vincere la prossima lei è
già in vantaggio Ma perché non l'ho
vinto io sono così bravo in inglese
Sì sì già l'ho visto quanto sembravo in
inglese prima hai detto pure Katia
invece che cake tornate tutti a posto
adesso inizia la seconda Challenge
Adesso faremo la Slime Challenge
prenderete tutti quanti gli ingredienti
vincerà chi farà lo Slime più bello
deciderò io chi sarà il vincitore della
seconda stellina
scarpe scegline uno va bene prendo
questo perché questo mi piace molto e
poi c'è un colore che ho sempre amato lo
volevo io quello rosa
Vabbè prendo il giallo Allora Ehi ma il
giallo lo volevo io perché non hai preso
il verde
[Musica]
scegliere mi prendo lo scarto degli
altri schiappe Scegli un colore prendo
questo questo è un colore che mi è
sempre piaciuto nelle mie creazioni
quando ero nel laboratorio Ninja
Birmania Anita Ah aiuto benissimo che
colore prendere prendo il rosa Wow c'è
un rosa pesca un rosa fragola quale
scelgo proviamo Rosa pesca e non vedo
l'ora di vedere come uscirà lo Slime con
questo Vitale prendine uno e allora ci
abbiamo arancia lime eh kiwi avocado
limone
produci viaggia prego ciliegia che è
rosso rosso ciliegia prendine uno eh sì
maestra io lo so già cosa prendere io
prendo il verde boccio così posso fare
anche gli scherzi
ai miei compagni
questo mi ricorda quando ero bambino che
faceva i primi esperimenti con le
palline Anita prendine una che belli
prendo questi bambini che belli Vitale
prenditi Ma io volevo quelli piccoli li
possiamo scambiare Anita ma sono più
belli quelli
Sì
[Musica]
ma io volevo fare le praline di moccio
non le posso fare adesso
un paio io dai grazie Vitale Allora
faremo gli scherzi agli altri a te non
te li faccio Oh Ok
tienilo scendo questo che è dorato
perché il dorato arriva dalla Polvere
delle stelle Io ho sempre raccolto la
polvere delle stelle Sì vabbè lasciamo
perdere e allora io scelgo questo
Celeste bellissimo Vitale ha preso un
colore a tua scelta Ok io prendo quello
blu Allora
fammi indovinare e io mi devo
accontentare di quello che rimane come
sempre vero
[Musica]
tanto ve la farò vedere io
e adesso vi darò la colla Chi di voi sa
come si fa uno Slime
vestito anche questo libro crea i tuoi
Slime in cui ci sono tantissime ricette
voi ce l'avete e qua ci sono tantissime
ricette per creare gli Slime bene voi
due tenete questa colla e voi due tenete
questa Ok grazie E ora che la seconda
Challenge abbia inizio benissimo
[Musica]
Io prima ho copiato dal telefono e non è
sempre giovane Vai su Instagram copiando
dal libro e non la metto in prigione
vuol dire
leggendo le mie ricette sono le mie non
le sto copiando da nessun altro
Basta con questa storia se no vi metto
tutti quanti in prigione Ok ok iniziamo
subito a fare lo Slime presto presto
presto fatto se non ci mette tutti in
prigione vediamo un po' di colla metti
qui ok
Sì ma non pensare che per questo siamo
diventati amici aspetta
Dominick basta così ok anche se non ho
il libro mi ricordo come fare gli Slime
Meno male allora mettiamo un po' di
colla trasparente
e Ma tu schiaffi non sai come si fanno
gli Slime devo ancora imparare nelle mie
ricette
chimiche saprò come fare ok Allora
inizia mettendo un po' di colla e ora
mettiamo un po' di colorante Vediamo
com'è questo color pesca
Uh ma sembra rosso proviamo a mischiarlo
vediamo di che colore diventa
Wow
Sembra un bellissimo Rosa adesso
mettiamo i glitter Celeste
Wow che belli mischiamo
è già bellissimo
e ora per ultimo facciamo le palline
Tienimi Ciao Sì non ne voglio mettere
troppe sono diventa troppo cruci Ecco
fatto e ora mischiamo
Wow
bellissimo
Ok Mi basta solo mettere l'attivatore
adesso
mettiamone poco per volta
E mescoliamo
1 2 3 e 4 gocce adesso
giriamo bene mescoliamo Ecco il verde
che io preferisco cosa stai facendo
verde moccio Non è vero
Ha ragione la maestra invece troppo
colorante sembra verde moccio non è
verde Muccio il verde
foresta mettiamo un po' di questo che mi
ricorda
abbiamo messo anche qua troppo anche nel
dito così
giriamo
bellissimo grande drogato verde Donato
mi ricorda i gioielli di mia nonna non
volte così va bene
così
e basta così
verde il verde moccio lo volevo fare io
per fare gli scherzi a questi stupidi
compagni
invece me l'ha rubata a schiappa l'idea
Vabbè Devo trovare una soluzione devo
cambiare colore ma come faccio Ah ma io
non so come fare
[Musica]
niente Ah ecco il mio colore verde Sì
rimane verde il mio colore
e poi devo prendere un'altra cosa
[Musica]
Io ho ripreso il mio colore maestra
posso tornare a posto ok
il colorante ciliegia che il mio frutto
preferito tra l'altro Guardate che
colore è bellissimo Ho fatto bene a
scegliere ciliegia Questa è più amarena
però voglio fare un Galaxy Slime
[Musica]
adesso aggiungo le palline medie Io però
ne aggiungo poche di queste perché nel
mio Slime le voglio solo come
decorazione non ne voglio mettere tante
ma non sto uscendo ancora il color cacca
mi serve più scuro come faccio a farlo
più scuro Ehi vuoi delle palline Eh
aspetta non guardare il mio Slime ancora
un segreto
uno Slime segreto Sì dammi qualche
pallina e girati Ok va bene ti ride
tutte ma come posso a farlo diventare
più scuro di così io lo volevo proprio
color
cacca maestra
questo colore non funziona bene tu non
avevi scelto il verde se tu hai
imbrogliato
ritornerà in questa prigione Ok ma non
imbrogliato perchè Nessuno c'ha le prove
come faccio a farlo diventare color
cacca Cioè più scuro come faccio a farlo
più scuro basta Aggiungere ancora
colorante perché secondo me tu non hai
il cervellino Ah ho capito Va bene prova
a aggiungere un altro colore
[Musica]
La maestra è stato lui non è vero È
stato lui alzati No no no ah
così no
non ce n'è ancora nelle mani
Aveva ragione la maestra aggiungendo il
colorante diventate esattamente il
colore che volevo io Ora sì che posso
fare gli scherzi Ah che bello il mio
Slime
No non puoi vincere tu di nuovo hai già
vinto la stella sì e quindi no Ora tocca
a noi Anzi tocca a me o io il modo per
rovinare
vermicelli però prima devo distrarla
Anita
Guarda la schiappa
niente niente
Sì No scusa Pensavo che ti stessi
chiamando sai non mi distrarre
[Musica]
Hai visto la tua stella perché hai
lanciato la mia stella lì perché sì
Perché tu sei troppo bravo a fare gli
Slime Ma adesso vai così perdi tempo
silenzio Silenzio
[Musica]
mille ha lanciato la mia stella
sembra proprio cacca Ma che schifo
è un po' sciolto dov'è che schifo perché
non si stacca dalle mani questa cacca
[Musica]
cosa stai facendo
la maestra mi dispiace stop tempo
scaduto Allora il voto è 2
Sì va bene allora se tu decidi tu vuoi
per me 10 a me non mi risulta Vabbè
allora il mio Slime È bellissimo perché
Hahaha
Che schifo
Che schifo ah ah
Ah
questi io dentro come la limessi tu e
chi li ha messi non lo giuro non li ho
messi io non ho messo io i vermi che
schifo chi ha messo dei due verbi Io non
sono stato Chi è stato Allora qualcuno è
stato
Fermo
lo vedi questo Slime Sì l'ho visto fino
adesso
[Applauso]
[Musica]
fatti
la maestra No no no ma volevo vincere io
No E volevo solo vincere io no maestro
Dai lasciami non lasciami è talmente
grave quello che hai fatto quindi sei
bocciato Oh figo io adesso ho più chance
di vincere allora è proprio Slime oh oh
oh Cosa sta facendo la maestra con il
mio Slime
faccio levato tutti i verbi è molto
bello perché
ha un bel colore ed è elastico cioè
molto elastico quindi il motore
benissimo quindi se il mio voto è
verissimo e schiaffi una presa
insufficiente e il bullo è in prigione
Basta che Vitale prenda un sufficiente O
insufficiente e ho approfitta io la
Challenge vediamo Che voto prenderà
Vitale Ecco il mio Slime
presentazione e voilà che cosa ne pensa
maestra Allora
il tuo Slime è molto bello Cioè è molto
elastico
quindi è benissimo lo stesso
anch'io ho preso lo stesso modo di alita
Ehi aspetta un momento ma se il tuo
punto è benissimo e il mio è benissimo
chi è che ha avuto questa Challenge
Allora la Challenge l'avete vinta tutti
e due quindi una stellate e una stella a
lui
sì il mio Slime è riuscito a prendere lo
stesso voto del tuo Ah beh Volevo
vincere solo io ma va bene anche così
che ha vinto anche Vitale dai anch'io
potevo vincere e non ci sono riuscito
Però va bene così
[Musica]
grazie grazie
La mia prima stella ma io ho due stelle
quindi questo vuol dire che sia Anita
hai vinto tu la Challenge
[Musica]
no due stelle per vincere E non è finita
qua perché c'è ancora una sorpresina per
il bulletto
no maestra no maestra no no no no no no
no no no no
no no no
Mi sa che il culo Ha avuto quello che ti
meritava voi lasciate mi piace perché se
questo video raggiunge i 5.000 mi piace
faremo un altro episodio con la maestra
cattiva scuola quindi cliccate mi piace
qua sotto e ora vi lasciamo Qua quattro
caselline su cui cliccare per vedere i
nostri altri video cliccate su quella
che preferite Buona visione Ciao
[Musica]